[Applaudissements]
vous en dis des conneries ça m'arrive
ouais maxime est ce que vous voulez
aller la rejoindre ou est-ce que vous
préférez rester de l'autre côté du pont
là vous savez là je pense qu'on est à
une dizaine de mètres
j'ai des roses d'une grande qualité dans
son bon ça sent la rose et je vais
galérer vous la portez avec coeur allez
amour fraternel pour l'instant vous
allez demander à la jeune fille est ce
que vous voulez qui vient de nous
rejoindre
jade elle n'attend que ça eh bien les
retrouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
max goeldi coupable de rien
regarde alors regardez comme ils heureux
[Applaudissements]